hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime emperor and black clover
confirmed what we were all thinking the
dark triad was only the beginning a
massive twist involving the strongest
devil and a deviously broken magic has
once again turned the spade kingdom more
arc upside down and the new ultimate
villain has just taken center stage the
black bulls are here and fighting to the
death and austin yuno are trying to
summon up the energy to keep fighting
after draining themselves in punishing
fights against devils and the dark triad
oh and by the way the next gate of the
cliff off is about to open this is crazy
so let's get into it if you guys enjoy
our black lover content and you want to
see more in the future just leave a
quick like and comment it only takes a
second but it really helps with the
youtube algorithm and if you're new to
the channel or maybe you watch our
videos but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications with the
way that youtube works now the only way
to make sure that you will actually see
our videos is to subscribe hit that bell
and then select the option that says all
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror finally this
video will contain black over manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned the chapter picks
up at the very moment that yuno manages
to slice through xenon's devil heart in
that moment xenon thinks about how
similar he and yuno actually are but
xenon has been defeated and yuno stands
triumphant which makes xenon wonder
where did the two of them part ways what
made them so different in the end
despite having such similar origins the
crucial difference seems to be the fact
that juno is still in the middle of his
vow with his best friend osta his vow to
remain friendly rivals and to strive
together to become the wizard king xenon
and his friend allen had a similar vow
about becoming the commanders of the
spade kingdom forces but after alan died
xenon lost his way without his best
friend to guide him to inspire him and
to keep him on the right track xenon
lost sight of his true goal he became
angry and jaded and with a push from his
devious siblings he ultimately turned
into a monster that is where xenon and
euno differ xenon was willing to
sacrifice alan's life in battle and the
consequences of that decision brought
about the corruption of his character
meanwhile yuno refused to sacrifice
language or any of his comrades and that
decision is what sets him apart from
xenon by the way it appears that xenon
might be dying in this moment but again
this is black clover so i'm not making
any conclusions although we know right
now is that he has been defeated as
parts of the palace begin to collapse as
a result of the epic clash between yuno
and xenon asta and the crew that had
fought magikula realized that yuno has
defeated zena asta smiles with great
pride at his best friends and rivals
achievement and now that all three
members of the dark triad have been
defeated the cliffhoth will close and
the spade kingdom war arc will finally
come to an end right right no of course
not despite the fact that all three
members of the dark triad have now been
defeated the advent of the cliff off has
not stopped in fact it is continuing
full speed ahead and this is bad news
for the people of the spade kingdom
remember all of those lower ranked
devils that have been pouring out into
the kingdom from the cliff off yeah they
are still coming out one after the other
and no matter how many of them are
defeated they just keep coming these
guys may not be the strongest devils but
if there is an endless number of them
then they are still incredibly dangerous
and deadly and if someone doesn't close
the cliff off soon the civilian
population will be overrun by these
devils in fact the current situation is
so bad that all the way in the clover
kingdom capital chibi julius is hunched
over on his knees and sweating profusely
he feels that something is off and that
something terrible is about to happen
and if julius himself is saying this and
if he is worried then something is
seriously wrong most of the time julius
is cheerful and carefree even in the
toughest of circumstances so his
behavior here tells us that the battle
for the spade kingdom is far from over
something big is about to happen
something that will eclipse everything
that we've seen up to this point back in
the spade kingdom palace dorothy is
using her dream magic to fight morris
but she is clearly struggling and morris
has the upper hand morris then reveals
the true nature of his magic
reconstruction magic and this magic when
combined with devil magic has become
absolutely overpowered lotus from the
diamond kingdom is also there and he has
betrayed morris because he wants to
protect his family from the chaos that
morris is trying to create but lotus
simply can't measure up in this fight
and he has already lost an arm
morris then reveals the shocking truth
unlike lotus he no longer has any family
attachments because his true purpose is
to be the messenger of the strongest
devil
lucifer we see lucifer's mouth
manifesting on morris's forehead and
lucifer himself is then able to speak
directly through that mouth wow this was
super gross but it's also a kind of cool
way to mark the halloween season lucifer
says that unlike dante morris actually
knows what he is talking about and this
confirms that lucifer never really
respected dante even though dante was
his human host it's clear that lucifer
was just using dante and let's be real
he's probably just using morris as well
however i've been saying for a long time
that the dark triad would fall and that
the real final villain will turn out to
be lucifer and maybe some other high
ranked devils and possibly the fourth
sogratis sibling once we discover that
he exists this chapter seems to confirm
that lucifer is the strongest devil that
is what morris says and lucifer
proclaims that he is about to fully
enter this world in his true body
according to lucifer the second gate of
the cliffhoth is about to open and as
soon as it does he will come forth in
his real body this is kind of weird
because i always assume that lucifer was
on the very lowest level of the cliff
off however morris then explains that he
used his magic to literally remake the
tree of clifford as a result the dark
triad are no longer required for the
ritual all that's needed now are the
magic and life force of yami and william
and that is why the advent of the cliff
off did not stop even after all three
members of the dark triad were defeated
morris's reconstruction magic seems to
allow him to essentially take anything
around him and reconstruct it into
another form and he appears to be using
the bodies of countless lower ranked
devils to create giant devil
frankenstein monsters that he then uses
to attack his enemies we know that he
can also take the magic of some people
and transplant it into other people by
using reconstruction to fuse grimoires
so it is clear that morris's magic has
endless possibilities now we still don't
know the full scope of reconstruction
magic and what exactly it can and cannot
do but i imagine that it is extremely
versatile and that it gets a massive
power boost from lucifer lotus knows
that he can't run away even though that
is what his instinct would normally tell
him to do because if he runs and the
devils win his family and all other
humans will be in danger so lotus
decides to stay and fight but it doesn't
look good for him as one of those
frankenstein devils attacks him directly
things look very bad for lotus and
dorothy but then everyone hears a
crashing sound and suddenly the wall
bursts open through the opening in the
wall the black bulls storm in to save
the day gray is there gauche is there
vanessa and gordon and henry are also
there and they all declare that they've
come to get captain yami back as the
black bulls prepare to face off against
morris and lucifer and all those franken
devils the chapter comes to an end wow
this was nuts the dark triad is down and
out yuno is triumphant but there was
literally no time to celebrate because
the new major villains are already here
morris and lucifer but how can lucifer
have multiple hosts at once clearly he
had a contract with dante and morris at
roughly the same time so is this
something that every highest devil can
do or is it unique to lucifer also are
there even more lucifer hosts out there
that we don't even know about this
revelation that lucifer can have
multiple hosts throws everything we know
into question also how strong is morris
right now presumably his already
powerful reconstruction magic now has a
devil boost and we can also assume that
he now has lucifer's gravity magic at
his disposal so keeping all of that in
mind i feel like morris hasn't shown us
even a fraction of his true power yet
furthermore morris seems like the type
of guy who would gladly accept the same
devil's heart deal as xenon did so we
really can't underestimate how strong
morris might be i don't know if he's
gonna end up being the final villain of
the ark but he's definitely up there so
can the black bulls actually make a
difference in this fight or are they
outmatched by morris and lucifer and
what about osta and the others can they
take morris down before the next gate
opens personally i think that morris
probably will be defeated by a massive
team effort but not before the second
gate opens and speaking of that second
gate isn't lucifer's real body supposed
to be on the lowest floor of the
underworld how did he get to the second
level and does it have something to do
with morris reconstructing the cliffhoth
itself finally who do you think will end
up being the final villain of this arc
will it be the combination of morris and
lucifer will it be the fourth zogratis
sibling and the time devil or will it be
someone else definitely share your
thoughts and theories down in the
comments below if you enjoyed this black
lover video and you want us to keep the
black clover content coming just leave a
quick like it only takes a second but it
helps a lot and if you're new to the
channel or maybe you watch us regularly
but you just haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a favor and make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting the bell and then selecting that
option that says all if you don't do
that you're still going to miss a ton of
our content even if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar and of course a big thank
you to all of our anime uproar patrons
who make videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma this
guy is an absolute mad lad and a
disciple of lord twigo himself and i
can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones that rise above all
other clans including ingrata algital
pate heffa hinokami in water the toasted
chi corey mcgowan the spike 8227 kaido
might be a gyarados dylan isidor spidey
lifetinel tungsten targus big buddhist
cody hebert and jeremy cummings finally
thank you also to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh the red-haired ravens steelers
on hell crews very gucci alicia octor
bonnie parks joanne garcia fat boy games
and jessica rabbit if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value to you consider supporting us on
patreon even a single dollar will give
you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you